The shortest distance here would be 29 miles. Good thinking if you found this
number. We can actually use the Pythagorean theorem in this case, since we have
a right triangle. We know that our town is due south of the interstate, and our
interstate runs from west to east. So, this means that the interstate and this
north south direction meet at a right angle. So, the distance between these two
mile markers is one leg of our triangle. And this distance, 21 miles, is
another leg of our right triangle. So, we can square this leg and add it to the
square of this leg to get the square of our hypotenuse. So, we'll have a
squared plus b squared equals c squared. When we square these numbers and find
their sum, we'll get 841 equals c squared. And then taking the square root of
both sides, we'll have 1c is equal to the square root of 841, which equals 29.
Great solving if you applied the Pythagorean theorem in this situation.